let's touch base with our caller from
the five one seven area code before we
run out of time who's calling today from
five one seven five one seven are we
muted no you're not what's going on five
one seven you there David yes I am you
there David
yes I am hi I was calling today to ask
you what do you think we can do to
combat cognitive dissonance within the
Liberal Party uh named the liberal and I
find that whenever a lot of people like
that last caller brings facts to people
if they talk redlining if you want to
bring up obama droning the hell out of
the middle east and starting new legal
wars if you want to bring up the
poisoning of our water for horotec three
decades scuse me three decades by almost
every single president with open you
nisshin's burnings people just closed
out it's not just the right like people
want to think the left is in a state
right now where we're closing down as
well we don't want to hear the facts if
they don't conform to our worldview in
our bubbles yeah what can we do on the
left to try to bring our own side back
to I might not like these facts yeah
listen I mean I we can only do this at
the individual level I regularly make it
a point on this program to say I'm on
the left the program leans left I think
that the left is right on way more
issues than the right but there's issues
where Republicans and Democrats are both
guilty of almost the same thing to
almost the exact same extent I mean you
can't do anything other than to tell the
truth and this is more of a behavioral
economics issue it's a psychology issue
it's more than partisan but being aware
of it is step one and step two is
pointing it out when we see it and you
know I try to do that every day so do
you think that there's much hope for
things getting better yeah I have hope I
mean that's one issue where I am
optimistic I think if we go back to
teaching critical thinking
at an early age if we teach civics and
philosophy starting in middle school I
think that we will predispose people to
be less subject to the cognitive
dissonance that you're talking about
that's my hope where I would argue with
you that you can look and people are
willing to poisons they're willing to
put their weight they're willing to what
oh okay it looked like he said willing
did he say willing to drink poison I
don't know this is a problem I'm trying
to deal with it here and it requires
some bigger systemic solutions that's
all the time I have today sorry to
everybody I didn't get to quick break
much more right after this